hey guys now you already know that i
love the rugged leather jacket look i
mean it's all over my channel and you
can check it out on the banner
and in this video i'm gonna show you
where to buy awesome leather jackets for
under two hundred dollars let's get to
it
[Music]
all right guys now if you want a good
quality leather jacket
you need to take out some money to get
it but be careful here because if you go
to the wrong store to buy it from or if
you just buy the wrong brand it might be
overpriced just because of the store
name or the brand name now
i found an awesome online shop called
angeljackets.com with a huge variety of
leather jackets that you can choose from
and they are all under two hundred
dollars it's under two hundred dollars
because they got discounts going on
right now now if you order a jacket from
them it will come in this package
all right
this is pretty cool hello and what
you've been waiting for
now
let me unbox it and i'll show you what
style of jacket i chose
[Music]
i'm so happy to see you cool
[Music]
we go guys it's the johnson dark brown
leather jacket now this jacket was 278
but it's now only 189 that's 33 off all
right guys now all that's left is to try
it on and to give it a honest review
let's do it
all right guys here we go
it feels good
[Music]
all right first impressions it looks
good it feels good
and it gives you that kind of captain
america feel
this is definitely a jacket that will
never go out of style
all right let me get into some details
here
this jacket is 100 real limeskin leather
it's not fake and it's also internally
fully lined with skin-friendly viscose
and when you look at the collar it's got
this awesome strap collar with a smooth
zip you know i really don't like it when
a leather jacket does not have at least
one or two inside pockets especially
if you want to put your phone
inside your pocket
but this jacket has four zipped exterior
and two inside pockets
one extra pocket for your cell phone as
well
[Music]
all right guys so all in all
in all honesty it's a great quality
jacket for a low affordable price the
reason for this is they just cut out the
middle man so it's cheaper for you now
if you want to check them out i've
linked the details for you in the video
description below i've also added my
five favorite jackets for you in the
video description that you can check out
now
if you haven't subscribed yet please
consider it and also click that
notification bell so you won't miss any
of our next videos and always remember
this
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys